l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 85 de Monsieur
Jean-François maillet à monsieur le
ministre chargé des transports de la mer
et de la pêche vous allez la parole mon
cher collègue monsieur le Président
Madame ministre mes chers collègues
force et de constater que depuis plus de
30 ans la vie la France vit au-dessus de
ses moyens et dans ce cadre
la SNCF largement subventionné par
l'État n'a pas été plus vertueuse des
projets sont allés trop vite et trop
loin en matière de LGV et le comparatif
avec nos voisins anglais allemands
italiens attestent de cette réalité pour
autant faut-il repousser ou à abandonner
la majorité des projets de LGV il est
vrai qu'à certains noms de dossiers
relèvent plus que d'autres d'une
politique de lobbying et d'influence
politique territoriale on peut en
trouver dans le sud-ouest dans le
sud-est sans oublier évidemment le
fameux projet Limoges Poitiers monova
destiné à dévier à la clientèle du
centre vers de la France vers la LGV
Ouest
mais s'il est un projet qui pour des
raisons techniques économiques doit être
réalisée et cela dans les plus hautes
délais c'est celui du Paris Orléans
Clermont Lyon le peuple ainsi que des
connexions possibles d'une dizaine de
départements des régions Auvergne
sentent Limousin et Midi-Pyrénées ce
projet a pour objet de doubler la GV
historique parions trentenaire et voué à
subir des rénovations très importantes
dans les prochaines années
des travaux nécessaires mais prolongés
provoqueront l'embolie d'un tiers de la
France dont sa partie la plus active
c'est-à-dire la région Rhône-Alpes par
ailleurs les départements et des régions
concernées sont aujourd'hui totalement
dépourvues de moyens à grande vitesse
par souci d'économie et d'amélioration
de l'existant la connexion de ces
régions peut être réalisée en se serrant
des lignes existantes rénovées et
modernisées à cet effet pour permettre
la circulation de train à grande vitesse
c'est le cas du POLT Paris Orléans
Limoges Toulouse le troisième avantage
de cette organisation et de permettre la
connexion ouest Sud Est évitant ainsi
aux habitants des régions de Limousin du
centre et de l'Auvergne de devoir aller
jusqu'à Paris pour se rendre dans le
sud-est mobilisant les dégâts
parisiennes la gare parisienne déjà
largement surchargé
enfin suivre la relance de la
consommation reste payée favori de la
nouvelle majorité il est aussi important
d'investir il n'y aura pas en effet de
relance sans investissement la
croissance de ce décret pas elle se
mérite elle investissement
l'investissement doit être le
déclencheur essentiel de la croissance
de la consommation et de l'économie
aussi tout en étant extrêmement sélectif
le projet époque doit être dans son
entier mené à bien ne pas le faire quand
reviendrait à renoncer un investissement
utile structurant et générateur
d'activités économiques
des territoires concernés
si j'avais su la nouvelle c'est-à-dire
que le fait que l'association pop est
exclue du comité de pilotage par le
Président et par le préfet coordinateur
j'aurais évidemment
orienter ma question différemment mais
je l'ai appris hier
je vous remercie de me répondre madame
merci mon cher collègue madame ministre
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vous avez bien voulu appeler
l'attention de Monsieur le Ministre
délégué en charge des transports de la
mer et de la pêche sur le projet de
ligne nouvelle Paris Orléans
Clermont-Ferrand Lyon vous en rappelez
un juste titre les objectifs initiaux
apporter une réponse à la saturation
programmée de la ligne à grande vitesse
actuelle entre Paris et Lyon et assurer
la desserte ferroviaire du grand centre
de la France comme vous le savez Réseau
Ferré de France a décidé le 4 juin 2012
de poursuivre les études du projet ainsi
une étape préliminaire aux études
préalables à l'enquête publique va être
rapidement engagée afin d'approfondir
certains aspects du projet évaluation de
ces impacts environnementaux
performances des desserts envisagés
avantages socio-économiques générés par
la nouvelle ligne à cet effet le préfet
de la région Auvergne a été missionné du
courrier du 2 août 2012 pour coordonner
cette nouvelle phase d'études et présidé
le comité de pilotage associant l'État
et les cinq conseils régionaux
directement concernés par le projet le
gouvernement suivra naturellement
l'avancement de ses études avec la plus
grande attention mais monsieur le
sénateur je ne peux pas ne pas évoquer
ici la question plus générale de la
planification des grandes
infrastructures de transport engagées
par le précédent gouvernement le projet
de schéma national des infrastructures
de transport niet présenté à l'automne
2011 par ce même gouvernement comporte
un montant d'investissement évalué à 245
milliards d'euros donc 88 milliards à la
charge de l'État à réaliser sur 25 ans
or ce projet de schéma ne dit rien ni
sur les priorités ni sur les solutions
de financement nécessaires à sa
réalisation c'est pourquoi il nous a pas
René nécessaire d'établir un diagnostic
global sur la pertinence et la
faisabilité du projet de snitt au vu de
la situation actuelle et des
perspectives rappelées par l'audit de la
Cour des comptes sur les finances
publiques il s'agit également de tenir
compte de la priorité que le
gouvernement étant donné au transport du
quotidien et à la rénovation des réseaux
existants merci madame la ministre
monsieur maillet
madame la ministre
vous connaissez la difficulté à
développer sur le plan économique des
territoires et notamment des territoires
ruraux dans cette période difficile pour
tout le monde je suis mère de
Châteauroux et président et sénateurs de
l'Inde donc ce projet-là pour nous est
extrêmement important
nous faisons partie de ce qu'on appelle
la patate creuse c'est à dire des gens
qui ne verront jamais passer une ligne
TGV mais pour le moins il faudrait que
nous soyons connectés or
le choix du trajet médian
indique que nous serions connectés
seulement à partir d'Orléans ce qui
n'est pas forcément une catastrophe pour
nous mais qui rallonge tout de même le
temps le temps de transport or
actuellement nous avons la lenteur la
confort et les pannes
si le projet maniant est maintenu comme
je vous disais ça exclut toute
possibilité de connecter l'image en deux
heures à Paris et à ce moment-là le
projet Poitiers Limoges retrouve sa
pertinence pas sur plein économique ni
financier parce que construire une
monovoir
je souhaite pas un président de la
République d'inauguré dans 10 ans une
ligne TGV monova mais enfin voilà alors
là dessus c'est très flou pardonnez-moi
de le dire comme beaucoup de postures du
gouvernement actuel et pour finir avec
un un sourire quand c'est flou il y a un
loup
pour nous il y a un loup et nous en
avons un peu peur merci